foreign
he's fine oh
this is gonna hurt her this guy's gonna
be very helpful I think I love that they
keep his identity mystery yeah easy down
we're not sick always trust the military
civilians by the river oh boy
not a good sign when he checks in with
the blocks not when he puts his their
life in his own hands first don't go
back for him okay
girl get down girl crawl they took out
him saying but there's a little girl oh
I wish they kept that in
yes sir oh boy
too many yesers yes sir oh yeah
boy
we're not sick sure
what's the Nicole Kidman movie with our
kids that's what he just lined it was
the same same exact line
oh boy
get up I'm sorry Pedro you don't have to
do this please stop oh damn late
oh boy
not this time not this time Soldier
that's my daughter
that's ain't gonna stop this it says you
could drive maybe no no down with the
fedra popcorn
he went Fight Club on him
oh no no no
right now Joe's like I saved the wrong
kid yeah I'm gonna punch you in the face
now
oh his buddy I love this season I hated
movies when they leave a gun behind
gotta grab a gun yeah well this is a
video game first yeah I know their dad
grab those weapons gotta add it to the
inventory yeah do they have a medical
kid yeah you've got to get everything oh
lovely lovely yeah lovely show HBO Max
welcome back to new rock stars The Last
of Us is finally here and for the next
nine weeks the break room is diving deep
deep into all of the lingering questions
you guys have about it so start
rationing Med kits and grab an
improvised question because this is the
break room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated all the nerdy news that you need
to know about we want to thank nordvpn
for sponsoring the break room today more
on them in a minute I'm Jessica Clemens
and with me today is Brandon
frickenberry oh I'm just happy to be
alive in these trying times hey if you
see a house full of old people freaking
out don't go inside of it don't go
inside stay where you are and also with
me Anna van Stanton oh what are you
buying what do you sell a wrong game
okay I'm sorry I'm ready wrong game well
here's how this show is gonna work folks
the first part of the episode will
always be spoiler free in terms of the
game we assume you have watched the show
now at this point the one first episode
of the show we won't talk about any
spoilers from the game if we ever do
that it'll be at the very end and we'll
warn you ahead of time so you can watch
us so safely we do recommend if you
haven't played the games maybe avoid
reading the comments if you're in the
comments be nice don't give the spoilers
away in the comments if you're in the
chat don't don't be spoiling people but
if you've never played the game maybe
just be wary be careful out there okay
there's lots of people out there there's
Marauders they're slavers uh uh there's
cannibals you got to be careful we don't
know who's in the chat folks just be
careful out there probably cannibals
definitely
horses in the chat if you're a cannibal
so let's get into this episode and kind
of recap it real quick remind you all
what happened this episode opens with a
juxtaposition of our world that we're
living in now right a round table
discussion with two epidemiologists one
with the fear of viral infections we
know how those go in our society the
other one though has a fear of fungal
infections which he turns out to be very
right about those fears I will say I
liked how in this one
um they they added in like it's already
really relatable with the pandemic
obviously but then they threw in the
whole thing about global warming playing
into the mutation and I was like oh very
smooth but they're like oh that could
never happen unless it warms up
as soon as he said that I was like oh
you guys are smoking indoors
smoking cigarettes
yeah so we we jump ahead 35 years from
that interview to 2003 we are introduced
to Sarah Joel's 12 year old daughter she
wears her same tour t-shirt from the
fictional uh band Telecom drops Allison
drops Pelican drops you don't know how
it can drops I listen to Pelican drops
more she wears the same shirt in the
game so folks if you're a gamer they
they're listening to you uh we meet Joel
a 36 year old construction worker and
his brother Tommy a veteran from the
Gulf War did anyone when when Pedro
Pascal said he was 36 rewind it yes to
be like wait did he say yes yes I did
because I was like no because Joel is
not 36 at the beginning of this movie
right because if you've played the game
you know they jump ahead 20 years so
it's like well he's going to be 50. he's
52 in real life so he's playing older
for this yeah and I think it looks good
old not a wrinkle on that yeah
Pedro mascara was so good but when he
said I'm 36 I said boy boy boy you lying
uh they all live in Austin Texas and
they're happy it's Joel's birthday happy
birthday Joel your daughter's gonna die
uh after school Sarah visits her
religious neighbor Connie uh and her
parents her Elder her Halloween mother
uh and their dog aptly named Mercy they
have this cute little dog save the dog
at all times uh Connie's mother has been
infected by the fungus at this point uh
something Mercy is cleanly aware have
it's a good thing to know that dogs can
detect this infection there are dogs in
uh in our world that are trained to
detect like if someone's gonna have a
seizure they can sense it ahead of time
dogs are very smart they pick up on
things what about cats uh cats are
trying to kill us if you die a cat will
eat you within 30 minutes
um did anyone else freak out the
scariest thing for me in this show was
when the elderly woman was moving in the
background it was so good oh that was so
creepy yeah I thought about you
immediately when the scene happened
because I was like oh this is a horror
show that's a random movie trailer yes
and it was so good I was I'm so excited
for my mom to watch this yeah I love
that and the tentacles coming out so
much more like gory and crazy they did
really good with the fun guy so creepy
well before grandma eats the family uh
Sarah leaves the house she takes home a
DVD copy of Curtis and Viper 2 a nod to
a moment from Last of Us Part Two uh and
she gives Joe a watch that she had
repaired without his knowledge to get
out of his drawer got it fixed don't
give it to him stole his money okay with
it we didn't steal all of his money
she's a good girl uh uh as Sarah falls
asleep on the couch Joe has to run off
to get to bail Tommy out of jail again
but he was fighting some Infected we can
kind of piece together things are slowly
falling apart in the world Suddenly It's
2 A.M and Sarah wakes up to the sound of
explosions I love the Green Flash that
you get when like Transformers explode
but very mysterious here like what is
that greenness after wandering over to
the Adler's house again why would you go
inside that Effingham he's a dummy even
the dog doesn't want to go in she's
attacked by the grandmother who has
turned uh Joel and Tommy arrive in time
to kill the infected and take off uh
love love beating it only with a pipe as
they drive away we get a sequence that's
pulled almost exactly from the game with
several long takes and lines of dialogue
that match with gameplay Tommy is
separated from Joel and Sarah who run
into a member of the military this uh
military member that was actually a
cameo by series showrunner Craig Mason
slipped himself in there does he get
double paid for that I don't know
absolutely not he begged to get in it uh
Soldier has orders to kill Joel and
Sarah and opens fire before Tommy shoots
him in the head Sarah unfortunately
suffers a gunshot wound and dies this
was brutal that was like so awful it was
brutal if you played the game it was
brutal here watching a young girl just
like die and that moment when it kind of
pans away and Tommy has to be like Joel
and like back and she's gone and she's
already dead I I like a they were like
we can't show like her actually died
Zoom away and then she's gonna and but
secondly I was like it hit harder in the
video game for me than it did in the
show yeah because it was so quick yeah
because I don't know maybe it was the
time that it took me to actually do the
game where I was like this took me
forever uh but like in the show I was
like oh yeah I guess she's like doing
dumb things oh I kind of had the
opposite for some reason the show
affected me more than the game and I
Gotta Give the props to the actress
because like that that dying was
incredible like I thought she did a
really good job uh it's just screaming
when he touches
I mean yeah I think it's just surprising
around whether you played the game or
not because you're not used to them
killing a young child especially the
child of your protagonist like so early
it was very shocking especially if you
had played the game you knew that the
game was about a man and a girl if you'd
see the trailer you're like oh I assume
this is the girl it's not the girl
we jump ahead 20 years later and fedra a
fascist militia group born From the
Ashes of the United States military has
set a perimeter Zone around Boston
called the qz or quarantine Zone
adorable several several several
quarantine zones around the country yeah
they're they're kind of spread out fedra
is like Loosely in control but is there
ever control I don't know uh we see a
young boy shamble his way to the
exterior and his question by federal
agents is Redshirt likely an homage to
the young girl Schindler's List they
also kind of focus on the shoes so you
see the shoes later after he tests
positive for the infection he's
euthanized and sent to a mass grave if
anyone ever tells you you get all the
toys you ever want was he tested
positive yeah I thought it was green no
it was red was it I thought it was right
up thought it was green and I was oh
they killed him anyway why did they
killed this kid I thought they were just
killing people because they couldn't let
that many people in and you know it's
the military nice stuff and I liked that
moment that's a moment that's not in the
game I thought it was really effective
and it showed like how kind of Ruthless
but yeah they did true to with the
humanized fedra a little bit in that
moment kind of she's the nicest person
to euthanize a child yeah yeah because
she doesn't have to burn the body yeah
the woman who can't do it you know and
then later in that in the scene we see
people getting like uh executed in the
street being hung so we know this this
Society doesn't play around right
they're taking it seriously uh we catch
up with our good friend Joel who does
odd jobs around town cleaning sewers
burning bodies yada yada and he sells
drugs on the black market to make money
he's a cool guy uh next we meet Tess
played by amateur if you might know her
from Fringe or mind Hunter uh she's
gotten her ass kicked by Robert's guys
after getting ripped off trying to buy a
car battery uh but she gets away thanks
to an explosion caused by the fireflies
they also leave these fun little
messages around town father the light
yada yada yada they're a resistance
group often referred to as terrorists uh
they blow up a Humvee and that gives
Tess an escape room very very convenient
uh this was very video gaming to me like
such a convenient moment like oh this is
the perfect time to get away yeah uh
meanwhile
um Ellie Moonlighting as Veronica we
meet her she's changed and interrogated
by Firefly members after they found her
infected by the fungus and still alive a
few weeks later can't take her she's a
feisty one too she's a fighter the
Veronica name change I didn't see coming
yeah I'm wondering how that might come
into play later yeah it's very
interesting feels like a setup we'll put
a pin in that uh Joe visits one of the
only people in the qz with access to a
radio tower as he awaits a message from
his brother Tommy this is a great
sequence too that shows like how people
in the town know him they're afraid of
him people who don't know him like hey
buddy you can't cut the line other
people like you better shut the [ __ ] up
this guy will eat you uh he's he's so
tough I love old Pedro pascals I thought
you were gonna say old people I love it
I love old Patriots stand up for your
country
so he's waiting for this message from
his brother Tommy and usually Tommy gets
back within a day but now it's been
three weeks Joel's like I gotta go get
him tell me where it is he gets
directions to the tower where Tommy has
been sending off messages from Wyoming
remember he's on the way in
Massachusetts it's a long track if you
don't have a car or even if you do have
a car and the world's falling apart and
we hear there's Marauders there's
slavers there's cannibals out there it's
wild out there we learned that tests and
Joint are together they share they share
a bed uh
they can't they it's a lot more steamy
in the show let's stream it in the game
uh they're looking for a car battery so
they can get out of town and go get uh
Tommy after finding Robert dead from a
shootout with the fireflies they strike
up a deal with Marlene played by Merle
Dandridge this is the only actor from
the original game reprising their role
uh she's the leader of the Firefly
section in Boston and they're not doing
so great uh she wants to smuggle Ellie
out of the city and they'll get their
car battery plus guns supplies and fuels
if if Joel and Tess agree to help
because this girl could be the key but
she doesn't tell them that at the at the
jump Ellie finds uh Joel's book of
number one music hits uh in a sequence
that reminded me so much of video games
like exploring a room and picking stuff
up uh she learns she very quickly
deduces a decipher for songs playing on
the radio 60s music is a nothing no news
70 music New Stock and she determines
That 80s music has an X but she figures
out that means trouble that means
trouble great right here in River City
right here in River City
don't start
take off for the boundary to qz as they
make their way out they run into the
same soldier's Soul Joel sold pills too
uh gotta keep the bag it's got dust on
it baby he checks them for the fungus
Ellie stabs him in the leg knowing
she'll be found out as effective Joel
flashes back to the moment his daughter
is killed and takes out the federal
Soldier to protect himself alien tests
him and Tesla in that Ali is seemingly
immune from the infection as they take
off toward the state house and leave the
qz behind their episode ends with the
radio in Joel's apartment clicking back
to life and playing Depeche Mode's never
let me down again an 80s song
what if it's 79
1979. it was like 87 or 9 88. you bring
up a good point though if you pick a
song that was like recorded in 79 and
released today these grown adults that
are working the radio station are doing
it it's not me who's guessing I don't
know so that's our weekend so young
so young uh that's our recap of the
episode really great really awesome I
think my first biggest question after
the episode ended is what have Joel and
Tommy been up to because without getting
into spoilers from the game the show is
implying that Joel and Tommy have been
keeping in communication fairly
regularly fairly regularly and this is
much more different than the game when
it's implied that they don't talk as
much and they haven't talked for a while
uh the device of the songs on the radio
is like a whole new thing that was not
in the game so what do you think they've
been up to communicating so much we're
like Tommy's replying within like a day
of like Joel reaching out to him like
what do you think they're doing out
there what are they what's all this
communication about well there's also
there's now Bill and Frank tied into
this because that's when she pulls up
the journal it's she's like who's Bill
and Frank f on it
um so they're introducing these
characters right off the bat from
episode one
um I don't I I think I know from
interviews that they're gonna focus on
and Bill's storyline a lot more as well
druckman said that so I'm excited to
delve into that see how also they're
involved
um originally in the game it was Bill
who helps them with the car battery and
getting a car and whatnot but it seems
like now they might also potentially be
have maybe some involvement with Tommy I
don't know yeah I don't know because uh
that's a good point like in the game
this whole McGuffin with the car battery
that was like weapons yeah they used to
be that they sold him weapons right
trying to get them back some lights
right so like is it was Tommy do you
think like Tommy and Joel could have
been planning like to move or something
or like I think they're just constantly
still looking for resources because
that's why they're going like a place to
go like a better place to be there
constantly yeah and I mean it's only
getting worse inside they're hanging
people for lower and lower cases right
for just like sneaking out I think
they're just constantly like I think and
I think that Park can still tie to the
games where Tommy is genuinely like I
you you deal with too much and I need to
leave like you haven't figured out how
to get away from your daughters death
and it's been over 20 years oh so I
think that situation is like Tommy being
able to leave and Joel being like no I'm
staying here yeah because it's implied
that Joel is uh uh has a drinking
problem maybe or is like turning to
doing drugs at least doing drugs he's
keeping the bag that he sells the pills
in and that's to go like
every drug lick the bag like like me
after a good peanut butter oh yeah
and yeah we see him like you know kind
of planning to go save Tommy but also
like I'm gonna get schnockered uh and
like pass out basically he's he has not
dealt with this and yeah that's a good
point maybe you know he playing we see
him blame uh Marlene for Tommy leaving
because like Tommy kind of got sucked
into the fireflies and then like was
angry with them and so he was like I'm
out of here but really that's a good
point like Tommy probably left because
of Joel like he was tired of seeing Joel
just like kill himself slowly even
before the all of the nonsense popped
off all the nonsense uh Joel was
constantly like I always have to take
care of you I always have to be there
and Tommy's like right right okay I'm
sorry yeah he went to prison I need you
to help me get out so he's probably like
you've always hated me why don't I just
go do it myself I would also there was
still a map in the first episode that
was like uh there's still a map that
said that they were going to Wyoming
or was it like that's where Tommy is
that's the he asked the radio guys where
this Tower is yeah oh it's where the
tower okay so if they're in Texas to
Wyoming yeah no now they're in Boston
they're in Massachusetts okay either way
still it's a long trip so if that
communication is like we have Bill here
we have so-and-so here and then we have
Tommy yeah they know where the
um the enemies could be the survival
people they know some safe spaces or
safe enough spaces but you gotta assume
everything else is bad also the size of
that map he's using for him to like kind
of even if you make a tiny little circle
that's like hundreds of miles probably
because it's the whole United States
it's not a big map I know but even like
once you get to that area you gotta find
that Tower still like it's not the
easiest thing to do hey hey don't ever
bet against Pedro Pascal it's kind of
like where's Tommy today oh he's in L.A
yeah yeah if you've ever like have if
you have friends in Los Angeles and
you're like oh my buddy lives out there
too do you know him
so I also wonder if this might be a
thing because this is after Tommy has
left the fireflies obviously
um I wonder and I'm not getting into
game spoilers here I'm trying to phrase
this delicately I wonder if potentially
Tommy moved on from there and went to go
One Direction and maybe if it was Tess
that was keeping Joel stationary in the
Boston quarantine Zone if like maybe she
had a part and not wanting to leave or
him wanting to have a stable life there
maybe but I don't know I Joel never
really expresses interest in anything
besides that right so I'm not sure if
maybe that was sort of a and Tess does
seem to have a good relationship with
Tommy in this yeah so I don't know but
maybe it was a Tommy wants to actively
leave Joel's like I just have this light
here now that I want to stay yeah he's
trying to save he he's he's comfortable
enough and you know if if he is like
really has this kind of like substance
problems you know the idea of being like
I don't want to go out there and not
have access to alcohol and pills like
that could be part of it too like I want
to maintain the structure I have but I
love what you're pointing out too
Jessica that like yeah the world this
little world is falling apart on its own
too the fireflies aren't getting
anywhere they're kind of stuck in the
mud they're just creating problems
they're hanging people there's barely
enough jobs for people it's not getting
any better like the Situation's not
turning so yeah we got to get out of
here we gotta find someplace safer
someplace just for us a little spot in
the U.S where we can set them down yeah
and hope that a mushroom doesn't grow in
the nicest way possible it's like the
dumbest idea I get so irritated in all
TV right right I came from a video game
that zombies don't exist the only time
zombies like do exist I think was
entrain to Busan where they were like
yeah
because I'm like yeah you guys will keep
leaving to go to another location that's
going to be filled with more zombies so
you keep going you're going to keep
running into them there's no escape and
we haven't we haven't named them yet the
games have names for the different
levels of infected and what they are
they haven't said like oh there's a oh
there's a clicker there these ones are
uh fast as hell yeah
like a super fast one the immediate ones
uh but yeah as people are infected for
as time goes on their infections can
become more severe there was also a new
poster in the federal office when the
kid went in that said the number of
hours yeah
because I remember it said 12 hours or
like a day for the leg then I remember
being like oh they are really trying
down on it that was great Exposition too
no one said it was just on the wall it's
like this is good to know like so this
way when the show that's one of the
things that zombie things too right
someone gets bit and turn a melee
sometimes they get bitten they hide it
for like a day yeah it's like I love
this idea that where you're because if
it's affecting your brain in theory it
takes it longer to get to your brain the
lower that's the plus side for this
being a 20-year Gap you don't have to
deal with the origin of them trying to
figure that out figuring out that you
have to take it in the head or whatever
or what have you that it Sprints they
already know those things and that is
why the games are good yeah when Mr
Grandpa got a bit when she walked in on
him and then he was almost immediately
infected I was like whoa and then
Dapper upper body infection she had the
nerve he was bleeding out he said help
me she said okay I went what I mean in
real life if an old man asked you to
help me no no no no bleeding out in the
neck in his room in his house the door
is open there are two killers in that
room and you are a 16 year old girl that
is insane he lived a good life probably
Sarah couldn't see it but as she walked
in you could see the empty wheelchairs
like that's right
the dog didn't want to go the person the
dog didn't want to go in Old
wheelchair's down that man's neck has
been into it yeah well actually no she
stepped on the blood first of the blood
first don't go in the kitchen note to
self don't hire Jessica for your
elements
if you are big okay if I am bleeding out
dead getting cut in the throat and I'm
the only person in my house the door is
open I will actually say run I will say
leave me because I Want You To Survive
will you do the meme where you go run
and I do the music on my Alexa you're
like hold on hold on zombie I gotta get
my spot I love zomb movies I love horror
movies my biggest pet peeve but I love
it I eat that [ __ ] up keep being stupid
great uh well we got uh more we want to
talk about this episode but first we
have got to think our sponsors today
nordvpn and one thing we've wanted to do
for a long time here on the break room
is have a movie club doesn't that sound
fun it's like a book club oh you don't
have to read reading sucks I hate books
the words are so hard our friends at
nordvpn have now made our dreams come
true and they want to help you be a part
of our Movie Club as well here on the
break room how did nordvpn make Movie
Club possible you ask well with just one
click nordvpn gives you access to films
and series that may not be currently
available for streaming in your region
nordvpn gives you the ability to switch
your location to one of 5400 plus
servers in over 60 different countries
and if you're ever traveling abroad
nordvpn will make sure you won't miss
out on your favorite content while
you're away don't worry about bandwidth
throttling when you turn on the nordvpn
it's not going to slow it down nordvpn
gives you the best speed of any VPN
service so your content Tech will be
streaming in that crisp high definition
so clear uh so so smooth for our break
room Movie Club this week we'll be
watching Knives Out And discussing it on
this Friday's episode of the break room
you're not going to want to miss it
Knives Out is currently not streaming in
the US you can't you can't you can't
it's not streaming anywhere but it is
streaming on Netflix Japan so we're
going to use nordvpn we're going to
watch knives out this week and we're
going to talk about it on Friday and we
want all of you to be a part of our
Movie Club to get in on this action get
nordvpn for yourself watch knives out
and join us on Friday for our Movie Club
discussion get your exclusive nordvpn at
nordvpn.com breakroom you'll get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift a bonus this whole thing is
completely risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee risk-free
again that's Nord
n-o-r-d-vpn.com break room watch nice
out join us on Friday we're gonna have a
lot of fun talking about it but now we
got to get back to some of this Last of
Us content okay here's another question
I have for you all how much more
pre-pandemic do you think we're gonna
get uh Craig Mason has talked about like
there's gonna they're gonna explore more
like before the outbreak or as the
outbreak was happening we got a little
more in this episode all that kind of
like pre-operate stuff was very new uh
you didn't get that in the game
scientist talking at the beginning the
scientists actually it's a whole new
thing uh and also like all the Sarah
introduction and Joel and Tommy and
stuff like a lot more there
um how much more do you think we're
gonna see through like flashbacks on
this show so many I think uh that
exposition of seeing the guard and the
light just beaming on him yeah and he'd
go flashing back to his daughter died
right that's gonna happen a lot oh like
moments are going to remind him yeah and
especially
oh my God especially what's happening
I'm hungry uh that's what I'm gonna say
as a zombie okay um and I'm gonna Sprint
quicker than I did as a normal faster
um it does that lady she was literally
wheelchair bound and now she literally
yeah anyways I think yeah it's gonna
come back in flashbacks of those things
it's gonna trigger moments in him
especially if Joel has a freeze up like
he didn't freeze up then but what if he
does yeah and Ellie's like I'm a little
girl I think that Soldier please correct
me if I'm wrong I know you will I know
y'all will too at least remember if I'm
wrong I think that's the first person
they have Joel kill which is not the
case in the game but I think that moment
is his first like oh I'm cute other than
the old zombie lady yeah
Ellie don't look oh yeah he's like all
right yeah I'm sure he'll come back to
it too because he uh that guy I
literally told him hey at night we'll
get you mistaken like being a dick but
like it was still like he was being this
is my job this is my job and you're
outside but come on this is the guy
that'll get you your pills you can't be
you also you're gonna lock him up you
can't be wandering outside I mean that's
why he's like my people are coming
they're gonna see me let you go I can't
have that happen bro I mean he's just
like well yeah
I do love this idea though uh of this
being his first like non-infected kill
because yeah the game with any video
game you know you're going through your
mowing down people uh and in the The
Last of Us game you're killing infected
but you're also killing non-infected
people who are standing in your way and
it can feel like a little bit am I a
serial killer what's happening Shoal is
not really supposed to be the Super
likable dude yeah yeah he's
[Music]
um and I think in this game they're
giving him a lot more redeeming
qualities I think they're trying to make
him a little bit more human soft or a
little more vulnerable
um and I'm excited that regarding the
flashbacks I think they've already
mentioned Riley
um Marlene mentioned Riley to Ellie
already so I definitely think we're
gonna get some of those flashbacks yeah
um and I hope I mean one of the things I
was most excited for was when he said
we're gonna see how it plays out outside
of America and I was like yes give me
all that
um so I hope I I am kind of looking
forward to the moments we see of like I
love how they hinted at it when when
um oh my gosh I'm playing Sarah went
about her day how like you would just
you would hear things happening or hear
things I love that the the revelation of
Jakarta we know there's some sad photos
that look like Indonesia so they might
like delve into the outbreak of the
source I was stuck on that because I was
also like as soon as the stuff happened
at the clock store I was like girl you
live through 9 11. you better hurry up
and then when she's in the car she's
like do you think it's a terrorist
attack yeah and I was like oh they're
aware that's great I mean like if you go
back and you know even a cinema any
movies and stuff that came out right
after 9 11 like it was like oh terrorism
is kind of a specter that gets brought
up a lot in movies uh so it would make
sense in 2003 she'd be like is it
Terrace like they were shoving it down
our throat that this was early 2000s
yeah I loved it I was eating it up when
they brought up Atkins I was like whoa
I'm on Atkins yeah this is ridiculous uh
yeah yeah and I really I did love that
opening sequence
um with the interviewers because uh Anna
you pointed this out in your primer for
The Last of Us now like the game doesn't
really tell you off the Jump what the
infection is how it spreads where it
started all that stuff you kind of have
to learn it by reading things in the
game or you hear audio tapes and stuff
starting from the very beginning of this
show and telling the audience like uh
you know we can all relate to like a
viral infection hahaha very funny we're
living through it it's a nightmare
um
no one's laughing and so as an audience
we're like we hear what this guy is
saying we know it's a real problem we
know it it's possible to kill a million
plus people millions of people with this
kind of thing is a threat but like we're
still relatively okay Society has not
collapsed we're moving forward to have
the other guy then be like well there's
also fungal infections and we have no
way of stopping it and it's like oh that
is scary and then he's like the Earth
could warm a couple degrees and make it
possible and we're like oh that's
happening oh my God so it's like right
from the jump they're establishing
here's how it started here's what it is
whereas like a show like The Walking
Dead right that's the big mystery what
is this thing how did it start how is it
it working we know that we know how it
works from the jump and I love that
about this show they even brought up the
ants the fact that it's a real fungus
yeah too yeah uh so yeah very
frightening very possible very scared
um I do think we're gonna get a lot more
pre-pandemic shots we also saw in the
trailer there was the mall there's like
the shot where she's there's a girl in a
mall that's from like a DLC that was
available for the game and we know that
takes place before the events of what we
see in Boston in the game it was like a
three weeks before
we we catch up with Joel he's always
there I wouldn't say when Joel got there
but he's always been there in our hearts
but I would love to learn more about
like what was what was it like before
the show catches up with them and all
that kind of stuff absolutely um can't
wait to see more can we just see more uh
Anna do you want to go through some of
like the changes we saw from the game in
the show absolutely I like some of the
big ones my mind was blown yes so so
many of the shots in dialogue are
actually pulled from the game I was kind
of my mind I did not think there was
going to be as much fan service as there
was like it really blew me away not only
we had shot for shot things but we also
had like all the characters except Ellie
which is really interesting had their
initial outfits on like their initial
shirts they were all the same it was
um so incredible Greg Mason has also
flushed out the world adding some new
details and changing things along the
way but um I do I mean
do I can I can I just start with things
that were the same that I really need
yeah what did you really like actually
no I
know I'm God I can start wherever you
want this is your part
I loved okay establishing shots with
Sarah's room right she had a bulletin
board that had Awards a little like
soccer sticker hidden in the corner it
established they were in Texas with a
little Texas sticker in the game
um whatever she is I know she has a
little like plaque soccer award so you
know she plays soccer they just hit so
many beautiful details details um shot
for shot that car sequence was
incredible yeah
um there was one difference that I
noticed that I thought was so such a
bizarre change was that when they drive
by the burning Barn in the game they say
it's Lewis's Barn in the show they say
it's Jimmy's box
I went back and rewatched that gameplay
sequence too of the driving because I
was like this looks so familiar but yeah
I don't know why they changed the name
like sorry Lewis I want to know what
happens
I don't know why they did that
the changes that they did make were
interesting yeah but
um so the some of the opening scenes of
the oh the opening scene of the show is
brand new to the to the show yeah uh
likely to tell audiences who are so
familiar with kova 19 that this is an
entirely different kind of infection
these this is not anything covid this is
completely different
um and they really as we said explain
that out so the outbreak begins in
Jakarta which is new to the show in the
game it started as I said in the primer
it was um from a mutated strain of the
cordyceps that came in from South
America from imported crops and so while
the FDA started to ban crops from
certain suspect countries uh it still
had by that point it's infected like 60
of the population
um and the sunset photos as you said
suggest that we may see the origins of
the outbreak maybe in Jakarta maybe some
other places during the start of the
Season uh we do spend so much more time
with Sarah in these opening minutes we
see her visiting neighbors going to
school fixing Jules watch in the watch
store there's this really cool like a
giant wristwatch kind of walk on the
wall where I was just like damn
that was like a popular thing in the 80s
like a big Swatch watch on the wall go
back and watch uh stay by the Bell
you'll see it at all the time put me
back baby put me back so we see that
whole process of her getting the watch
fixed whereas in the game she basically
just says here Papa it's your birthday
um and they also I don't think that they
say in the game that uh she took about
money I think I think it implies that
she earned it herself somehow amazing
in the show she's just straight up like
I took your money back the change Mercy
the dog Mercy the dog is spared in this
show uh in the game she gets okay by one
of the infected
foreign
by the way speaking of like animals in
nature and what not one similarity that
I really loved was that in Joel's
bedroom hanging above his bed he has
like if they're in the game throughout
his entire house he has these like weird
nature almost looks like it's off like a
postage stamp uh little photos art
drawings of animals and they have that
same sort of style of moose painting
hanging above his bed I don't like the
game man I really liked it but regarding
Joel we get a lot more background
information on him this time in regards
to his time in the Boston quarantine
Zone his relationship with Tess in the
games all you get is a little a little a
little cheek wiping of the blood you get
a an off-handed comment about like oh
it's kind of like a date you're romantic
whatever
um but it's way more ambiguous in the
games in this one if she gets in that
bend immediately but hey honey buns I
thought that was sober up it's loving
time
stop I haven't had a shower in a long
time it was so because I was like I
assume they're together in the games but
I was like they could also just be like
really weirdly platonic yeah their
relationship could either be me and
Tommy's or it could have been me and
like uh Idris Elba yeah actually in love
um no and so I genuinely was like oh oh
one of the cuddle scene happened I went
oh right off we know I was wondering
like these type of shows like and they
did the movies too I was like how horned
up can you really be in the qz watch
watching three people get hanged today
like can't wait to go home and have some
sex like no you want to get that you
gotta get that anger out here
uh we also learned that but I'm just
gonna we're gonna move quickly along
um HR we also learned that fedra is
hanging people for unauthorized
entrances and exits from the queue
they can't risk an infection it's
spreading inside of the qz it would wipe
them out immediately but I don't like
the the shows like how I love when and
movies and shows are like this is how
bad we've gotten as people like when the
when [ __ ] hits the fan we have to go
back to like public execution to put
fear into the people's eyes they also
changed the fact that um they were
publicly hanging people in this one
whereas in the game like you see them
via gunpoint yeah about public
executions but this is the yeah straight
up
honestly just yeah
hang them in front of everybody that's
work oh God that's not clean um another
big difference is that in the show Ellie
is straight up chained to a wall and uh
doesn't seem to know Marlene very well
when she comes in and talks to her in
the game she does she's pretty much
traveling with them uh she knows Marlene
they're cool uh and yeah so this that
was a pretty big difference of no you're
getting mandatorily scant kind of
treated as a prisoner yeah I liked it
though I like that I like that change of
yeah I'm like I'm forced to hear but
also I know on edge yeah right she's got
to constantly be on edge also that okay
okay that little girl was typecasted she
is great at cursing she's good she loves
doing it
kept that from baby to like team tween
she is keeping that cursing out people
first laugh out of me when she said
three like that's impressive that's a
good line reading if you can get me to
laugh at the word three when she's
counting up to ten when she keeps trying
to get her knife back I mean it's just
like great just and Joel just be like no
yeah she stood up and was like wow I've
been outside nature I was like [ __ ] get
down down get down I love her so much
she's fantastic I can't wait to see what
else she does with it so also in the
show Tess and Joel are looking for a car
battery from Robert uh who tries to sell
a burn battery to another party uh in
the game they're looking for they're
talking about Firearms weapons that uh
Robert has sold off when he wasn't
supposed to to uh the fireflies
basically Tess kills Robert in the game
whereas he's killed there's a standoff
with the fireflies in the show so that's
what I was saying earlier about how Joel
in the game has a lot more blood on his
hands and is a lot more ruthless before
he ever gets to killing a guard or
whatever
um in the game or in the show they
neatly were like like oh look all of
these people have already been killed
and off screen like they don't have any
blood on their hands it's fine
um and then the the radio Cipher is a
cool new detail from the show which I
really love it gave a great little uh
oomph when when the the Depeche Mode
song played in the end it was fun it was
such a cleaning because it starts with
them what so good for them what
generation is this song what generation
is it I genuinely was like I want either
every episode to start with uh the
conversation between the scientists and
it kind of uh frames you'll get a little
bit more or I want it to end with the
song so we know whether they're in
trouble or they're safe or nothing we'll
have to keep our eyes open for that I
would love every episode to start with a
little more a little free pandemic scene
that would inform what the episode's
gonna be kind of this week
because we talked about the end of the
beginning how the credits had that same
branching yeah fungus and a lot of the
credit sequence I love the songs they
used throughout the show it sounds just
like the gaming kind of slow guitar
stuff it's such an HBO so many game
feeling moments like the driving in the
car the exploring of the room the
overhead shot of the tanks driving
through Boston like really cool stuff uh
every episode of our of our last of us
have to show here on the break and we're
gonna do a kill count okay lots of kill
counts this time Joel he gets he gets
two kills he gets two kills this one we
see him like uh kill the old lady we're
counting we'll count that one we'll
count down
and then he kills the soldier are we
gonna be accounting infected this whole
time we're doing it this is important
infected important infected Tommy gets
one kill under his belly kills that
Soldier we see that happen he does
technically Jill hits two people with a
car well I mean Tommy hits Tommy's
driving Tommy's driving they survive
yeah they survived by proxy time because
the neighbor we love that ice cream
moment of like uh Joe what are you doing
uh test it and have zero add zero kills
she got away from the bombing didn't
kill anybody Ellie had zero kills this
time she should have a great stabbing
we're gonna give the fireflies eight we
looked back how many did Sarah kill
Sarah Sarah
got killed negative one negative one uh
the fireflies got about eight between
the bombing uh and then uh kind of them
shooting Roberts guys later Roberts guys
took out a couple it's hard to tell on
that hallway sequence uh and we didn't
put it in the script but we'll give the
airplane 160 kills well I'll say 117
Souls on board 50 in the street good job
airplane you did a great job did a great
job the airplane was in that was like
frightening watching those planes coming
in first and then you hear the screams
and they look back and they're like
playing coming in I would have died by a
plane crashing into me easily easily
crazy I can imagine being on those
flights when those people started
honestly
in La I thought the traffic was the
scariest part actually how would I get
out of here we just got to stay here we
just got to deal with it we got to make
our time with what we can you guys
that's it for this episode of the break
room we'll be back next week to discuss
episode two but we also do this show
every day live at 3 P.M talking about
all the nerdy news and all the stuff you
love follow me at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow Brandon at grin and
Barrick and Anna it's Anna vanston on
Twitter subscribe to the break room
wherever you get your podcast yeah
thanks for your hard work today guys
these are rational cards for the day I
really appreciate you guys how much
money can I get for cleaning up poop
give me the back too when you're done
okay
Jesus bye
[Music]